je crois que après tout ce que tu viens
de me dire je dois partir
surtout après tout ce que tu viens de me
dire je dois partie surtout après tout
ce que tu viens de me dire je dois
partir
surtout après tout ce que tu viens de
dire je dois partir c'est la fin d'une
belle histoire
ça va pas ça c'est pas bon il faut jouer
plus à l'américaine il faut jouer
décontracté il faut jouer avec les
objets vous avez les objets vous jouez
avec les objets décontracté à l'actors
studio comme il fait james dean il faut
faire american actor studio décontracté
vous comprenez vous n'aurez pas
américaine à problèmes
je crois que
après tout ce que tu viens de me dire je
dois partir c'est la fin d'une belle
histoire fantastique extraordinaire ça
c'est sensible et ça ça me plaît ça et
voyez-vous les autres comédiens français
et étrangers qui étaient ici prêt à être
auditionné vous avez chacun médian texte
de votre choix
c'est à dire un poème une fable un
extrait de tirages classiques ou encore
vous dites un poème ou encore jean fabre
si vous voulez vous dites mais très vite
la glace ou encore un fois l'objectif a
accepté la création encore le parcours
va demander à monsieur moi aussi je suis
belle monsieur oui n'ai pas l'accent
beaucoup de travail
laissez-moi jugé sous moi donc cette
troupe s'avance et porte sur le front le
maire l'assuré nous partîmes 500 mais
par un prompt renfort nous nous vîmes 3
et mêlant arrive encore à nous voir
marcher avec un tel visage les plus
éprouvantes et reprennent leur courage à
vous passer à côté vous allez signer le
contrat
maintenant je vais demander à monsieur
fall à berck volkhine friedrich annonce
car hellmuth vous également comment
l'avez-vous des vinyles comme ça pouvait
lire un texte lu et bien sûr mais avant
je voudrais vous dire et comme j'aime
beaucoup vos artistes français dans la
mousse curie petula clark et rika zaraï
dalida etc des rares et scélérate
s'élèvera le texte la femme fine à dire
aux fans clubs français mais rien pour
arranger tout le monde là oui bien sûr
il faisait beau aujourd'hui sur la
compagnie
nous avions des idées mon père ma mère
mon grand père m'a cramé est ce qu'il
restait de mon arrière quand on est
heureux de prendre la 4 e chevaux et
daligand battus nous nous installâmes au
bourg de longo sera 2 à 1 m 25 1 m 30
pages libres et s'étend sur rue et à la
fin du déjeuner mais grandir je vais
vous raconter une histoire c'est
l'histoire de tout haut le fameux tour
et dans toutes les histoires de tous et
tout donner dans les connais et ils
chutent alors là ménez l'airmac elle vit
dit tout le monde connaît leur élan vers
la rive la maîtrise des frais pour les
sacs poubelles dori gold fund rigole
tout un tour à tour de répondre madame g
les zizis calendrier la course était
bien celui là vous passez à côté vous
signer le contrat
il y en a plus c'est fini très bien allô
oui mais l'aspect mon capitaine je viens
d'un coin ces trois là oui il vient de
signer un contrat de cinq ans pour la
légion étrangère mais l'espère gravité
mais respecte dacquois